Film Courage: You talk about
dilemma which is part of your tools?
Jeff Kitchen, Dramatist / Author / Founder
/ Consultant: Yeah and that would be pretty
much what I go to next because the way that
I work with dilemma is I'm looking at that
right from the outset in developing the story.
You can see that even as I'm playing with this
broad array of possibilities for this
story. I keep coming back to well if
the robot had been programmed to do this and like
what's unacceptable to the robot and
what might be equally unacceptable and
how does that how is that impacted by commands
that are given by the robot's operating system um
by the robots sense of morality one of
my favorite quotes which I thought about
for a flickering second about a half an
hour ago it's by a writer George Saunders
and he says character is the governing
element of life and is above genius and
real character is something that's very important
and mere genius is just some other
smart dude who could be completely crazy
but he's wicked smart and it's like but he's
destructive or it's like it's it's just genius
that it kind of like throw a stick and you can
hit a genius but half of them are screwed up
character is is substantial and that could be
something that the robot is really wrestling with
and I really like the the image
of data the character who's
I think it had a positronic brain it was
absolute state-of-the-art computer technology
built into an Android I don't know if it
synthesized human and robot or if it's just
a pure machine but his hunger
for Humanity and curiosity about
aspects and foibles of humanity is
intriguing it was something I haven't seen
that show in many many years but I always liked
data and I remember one show
he even became human for
a half an hour in the Holo deck or
something like that but at the end of it all
he understands what a joke is and he's like
oh that's funny even though he's no longer
in the mindset that had him acting really
like a human Spock did that sometimes too
where he would become more like a an impulsive
wild animal than a rigidly controlled logician
and he'd go into these different states and be
goofy and wacky and funny and all that stuff
so just in terms of focusing on trapping this or
automaton in a dilemma of magnitude a
dilemma that matters to the audience
there's a lot of raw material for that here
and
it seems as though
there might be altruism on one side
like it's unacceptable to give up
a sense of what's right of doing the
right thing of being able to be incapable
of doing really powerful world-changing things
someone who's kind of like was raised to be a
brain surgeon and like they're really trying
to do good for people and that's built
into who they are and why they operate
so that's an interesting thing to
kind of just sit there and let it
float like the need to do good a moral
compass and even just a moral compass
knowing what's right and what's wrong so then to
countermand that or to be the opposite of that
but equal because you want equally unacceptable
Alternatives that's where you get that Robbie
the robot short circuiting in between two things
if one if one side of the other of the Dilemma is
more unacceptable than the other than
you have a path of least resistance
and electricity will always take the path
of least resistance but if you have equal
resistance then you block it you have
impedance and it heats up and electricity so
I know what this automaton looks like caught
in this dilemma because it looks literally
like Robbie the robot short circuiting like
it can't it's like unable to process command
and so I know that I want to achieve
that but it's a question of what are
the two alternatives that are being
sort of not just posed to this automaton but sort
of foisted onto this but automaton forced like
Sophie's Choice it's not like oh that'll be a fun
Choice which kid do I sacrifice it's horrible it's
like I don't want any of this but it may not be
that extreme but we want something substantial of
magnitude that really impacts an audience
and you want not only magnitude a dilemma
that matters to the audience but you want it to
where the audience can relate to it personally
and that's an important aspect of working
with dilemma because if you're trapping a
protagonist in a dilemma and the average person
in the audience can understand it intellectually
but has no emotional connection to it then they're
like I see what they're talking about but I
don't care so one of the questions I'm always
asking my students is once you have a dilemma
trapped between two equally
unacceptable alternatives
can the average member of the audience connect
to that and so what I say is like pick somebody
who like lives down the street that you don't
even know and sort of study them indirectly
they might be someone who's like a graduate
student in dance and really creative and
drives Uber at night to make ends meet and
it's just a regular person down the street
so you've got your character trapped in this
dilemma can that person down the street that you
don't really know or don't know at all can they
connect to that or is it like because you want
your average member of the audience who's just a
plumber taking his kids to the movie or whatever
do they see themselves in it
because if they don't then
they're less connected to it and they say that
the deeper you go the more universal you get
so if the movie is about a contractor in
France who's caught up in a tricky situation
it should be so that like a doctor in Australia
can watch that movie and go I don't know anything
about building houses but his dilemma of
like Duty versus honor or something like
that like I can totally relate to that so it's
like what we want as we work with developing
a dilemma for this automaton is to make it
so that the average member of the audience
looks at that dilemma and goes wow I'm caught
in the same dilemma it's a different set of
circumstances but I'm caught in that exact
same thing and I don't know how to get out
of it maybe this robot can solve the thing
that's paralyzing me in a fundamental way
then the audience cares that much more
and it's a visceral connection it's an
emotional connection not just an intellectual
understanding it's interesting to try to
trap this robot in a real quandary they do a
decent job of that in the Will Smith movie Eye
robot Will Smith hates robots because they
tore off his arm at one point he's a cop
the head of this huge corporation
gets thrown off a 30-story landing
and Will Smith is brought in to investigate and
everybody thinks this robot killed the master
but and Will Smith hates that suspect robot from
the beginning because he's prejudiced against
all robots he hates them all but he begins to
perceive that the robot that is under suspicion
has unique insights and is the total opposite
of what he thought and it's at the and that
robot was actually reprogrammed by the old man
before he was killed and that robot is there to
help Will Smith stop the robot Corporation from
doing something treacherous I don't remember
exactly what it was I think it's a robot army that
they're unleashing on the World to control them
but it's interesting because
because that robot
is either raising interesting questions
in Will Smith's mind or Will Smith is Raising
interesting questions in the robot's mind
I can't recall but that's just a movie I've
seen that has similarities to this type of
potential story and like I can feel the presence
of the Dilemma even if I'm not able to articulate
it clearly at this point because I'm still kind
of inventing what these two equally unacceptable
Alternatives could be but I know I know how that
robot feels trapped in that type of situation
I have an emotional connection
to what that does to this robot
and
so as I sort of try to conjure what
these things might be it can be helpful
to look ahead to the point of Crisis
where the Dilemma comes to a critical
juncture around the three-quarters point
in the movie around the end of act two
because we want the Dilemma to kick in
somewhere around the end of act one where
we've we've gotten to know the main character
the stories developed and as as the story gets
up to speed like the full complexity the story is
All kicking in we want this robot to be trapped
in this dilemma of magnitude either before
the end of act one or by the end of act one
and we want that Dilemma to extend throughout
act two where The Dilemma goes critical prior
to that the robot is like I can't pick in either
direction and the same with Jake Hoyt in Training
Day I can't let go of this opportunity but I
can't do what Alonso is trying to get me to do
and so that dilemma is going to go critical around
the end of act two and then the protagonist has
to make a decision about the dilemma and take an
action about it now that it's gone critical and
then the ending of the story is the resolution of
the Dilemma the active resolution of the Dilemma
by the protagonist that conclusively resolves
the Dilemma so the Dilemma is like fully engaged
before the end of act one or around the end of Act
One it builds an intensity all throughout act two
to the point where it reaches this critical
juncture that forces the protagonist to make
a decision and take an action about the Dilemma
that he or she couldn't previously decide about
and then the end is the resolution of the Dilemma
so the Dilemma encompasses most of the proportion
of the script it's not something that happens
for five minutes in the story it's something that
takes up most of the story and if you look
at the movie Almost Famous by Cameron Crowe
he won best screenplay for that he said
the the kid who's the reporter he said he
he re he can't become friends with the band
because then he's no longer an objective reporter
and if he does become friends with them they'll
try to make him write about how cool they are
so he he loves this band it's unacceptable to
not become friends with them because they're
the coolest creatures around and he's uncool so
he's desperate for that and yet his mentor the
Philip Seymour Hoffman character says do not
become their friend because they'll make you
into a puppet and write about how great they are
you want to be an objective reporter and really
stick to your guns on that and Cameron Crowe
said that dilemma is what the movie's about
and if you look at it again you can see that
constitutes the full proportion of the script
it takes a little bit of time of setup
to get to get to know him he gets in with
the band starts traveling with him but
after he's really in there he has great
opportunities to become friends with them
but he really wants to be a good reporter
so the Dilemma is
constitutes much of the proportion of the script
and the way I describe it sometimes is like it's
like a whale in your living room it doesn't
take up every square inch but it takes up
the full thing you can still walk around it
and stuff but it's not a little thing in the
middle of your living room it's the Dilemma is
constitutes the full proportion of the script
so all of that to say that as I work
to conjure what these two equally
unacceptable Alternatives could be that paralyze
the protagonist for much of the script one way to
um see what these might be more clearly
is to look ahead to the point of crisis
like okay so at some point this dilemma is going
to come to a make or break point which is very
much the gun to the head on the protagonist
like you don't get to spend any more time
thinking about how you're gonna what kind of
decision you're gonna make about this dilemma
you have to decide now that's the nature of a
crisis it demands immediate decision and action
and so sometimes looking ahead to
what the crisis might look like
can help you see what this is by sort of looking
through the opposite end of the telescope or
seeing it from a different point so if I'm
this robot and I'm trapped and I can really
feel these things I just don't know exactly what
they are yet and that's okay but at some point
there's going to be a make or
break crisis about this dilemma
yeah and it's really about morality
like versus ambition I think
like if the son of the leader is going
to make eight trillion dollars overnight
I can see the robot feeling morality but
does a robot have that type of ambition
like does it care about eight trillion dollars I
don't know I mean like I have 13 year old girls
and they're very aware of money now and like
it and are interested but when they're eight
they get Christmas money or and we like put
it on their desk and they like didn't pay
any attention to we'd find it like under a
book the next week or they just they didn't
it didn't mean anything to them yet so like
to what degree might an automaton value this
massive amplification of power and possibility and
all that and certainly if it's an AI then it could
certainly have been imbued with characteristics
of the owner that growing the company is really
important and is important to the survival of
the business even survival of the automaton
if the business got shut down then maybe the
plug gets pulled on the Autumn on the automaton
but it seems as though like
being raised by the owner programmed or created
I don't know if the money is
as important as the capability
you know so is the is the
Sun telling the robot look
some people are gonna die in the process
of this or maybe the robot comes back and
says this plan you're putting in place
a whole lot of people are going to die
and maybe the robot hadn't really connected
that yet and the owner is like well yeah but
that that's how progress is often made
and the thing is that if our company
achieves this Monopoly then our
capability to help so many more people and
in other words appeal to the altruism of the
robot or the moral compass or something like that
is possible and you can see I'm just
kind of feeling my way along with it
and I'm not even sure what an
ambitious robot even looks like
but it's programming it's compulsion it's like
not so much more is better but more enables
more function more capability more something
it's puzzling like I'm not sure
so
but so I'm not exactly sure what the crisis is but
I can see a sense of what decision and action in
the face of Crisis might look like because the
the crisis breaks the paralysis of the Dilemma
it forces a decision and action and they say
Aristotle said that decision and action in
the face of Crisis reveals the true character it
strips the mask off you like you don't know who
your real friends are until you've been through
a crisis with them the classic example is the
big strong guy jumps up and runs out screaming the
little guy jumps up and Saves the Day so you don't
know what people are really made of until they're
forced by a crisis to show what they're really
made of and I could see the robot really trying
to do the right thing at the point of crisis
but to get to the resolution which is the
resolution the conclusive proactive resolution
of the Dilemma by the protagonist once the robot
takes a stand to try to do the right thing at the
critical moment then he's got to fight to the
finish with the Sun to get through the last
15 minutes of this movie in a real knock down
drag out fight that the robot May well lose uh
and there could certainly be a creative
resolution for the automaton but it's going
to have to grow and think differently and disobey
key things and cleave more closely to key things
some values that it's been programmed to value to
to uphold will be shattered and some values that
has been programmed to want will be Amplified
as the way the way people do in real life so
the one thing that's really
crystalline is decision in
action I can see the robot is really
going to try to do the right thing um
so does that inform
what the Dilemma consists of let me just sure
and I just thought of something too that might
be driving the sun aside from money and that is
notoriety and fame that will come with the and
he's the the the son of this sort of brainchild
and then he's the he maybe social media wasn't
around when the father was building the company
and now maybe the sun is not 30 yet and now he'll
be the successful 30 under 30 and so there's all
this press that he wants and that's also driving
him yeah which is also kind of Madness and sure
that kind of stuff the narcissism and the the need
for power and maybe the father was never around
because he was just working 19 hours a day and
the kid has a a sort of out of proportion need
to be loved or to impress or to be validated
and he had his whole identity was I mean
growing up in the Bay Area I knew people
that their children were from someone's owned a
tech company and that was the first thing out of
their mouth and and wasn't always the healthiest
Dynamics but it was high and my father was so
and so and I think that's a very real thing and
unfortunately it just happens absolutely so maybe
he needs that it's driving him and also the social
media accolades and the press to be in all of the
financial papers as yeah absolutely yeah and we
want to build complexity into that but that's
where the Enneagram is so useful to dimensionalize
that sun in a way where you understand the Sun
but you still see him as a monster but
he still has very interesting aspects and
um
you know you see
up and coming business owners who are
really ruthless with their competitors
and then after they make it big
they're like giving money away
to everybody but they destroyed
multiple businesses to get there
so it's like you know
again again it's the the ambition
versus moral compass type thing
now the other interesting model for dilemma
to try on is something that comes from
my knowledge of Tootsie which is that
Michael Dorsey's a male actor who's
very talented actor but a huge pain
in the ass to work with and he's
really inept at relating to women and when
he dresses up as a woman and gets hired
all of a sudden he's got a career of fat paycheck
respect as an actor and relationships with women
that he wasn't capable of doing as Michael
now that he's Dorothy and he sees women from
a totally different point of view now that
he's Dorothy and he becomes Dorothy becomes a
crusader for women's rights whereas Michael was
kind of the person she'd be crusading against
so and and there's all kinds of ways in which
becoming Dorothy is disrupting Michael's life
in both major and minor ways so Michael can't
let go of Dorothy because it's the best thing
that ever happened to him but he can't keep
being her because it's the worst thing that
ever happened to him and it kind of cooked down to
like Dorothy is creating him like literally making
him a better person and destroying him like kind
of taking him apart as all these things happen
so I'm like I want to like try that on
for a possibility for this automaton is
there a way that this situation is
offering a lot of potential upscale
to the robot and yet is also destroying
now here's something that could actually
drive a robot or give a robot ambition so
what if we talked about the possibility of
the robot regenerating the old man in humanoid
form even if it only is 20 minutes based on
sneaking around to use the equipment in the
in the manufacturing facility kind of like the
Tyrell Corporation where they can make people
could the Sun tell the automaton stick with me and
help me pull this off we'll make eight trillion
dollars overnight we'll be worth 80 trillion this
time next year and we'll be getting up towards
a quadrillion in five years like boom like we
can now move on to the master plan of actually
genetically building people so
you the automaton could have a
human body and actually walk around and
get cut and have Bo and go surfing and
get sunburned like all the things that you've
always wanted see that's something that could
really like the robot is like I want that and
almost like an out of proportion irrational like
I'm desperate to have that nothing's going to make
me let go of that but I'm also being asked to look
help execute a billion people with this
contagion so that we can sell the cure for it
and that's going to make me human and so
see how I was like I was feeling around
for how can a robot be ambitious what
does he care about does money mean anything
at all to him but that like that's something
and it's it's Pinocchio the the wants
to be a real boy and it Taps into Data
and it doesn't have to it doesn't have to
it doesn't have to come from a place that
necessarily makes sense from the outside
so it's not you look at that from outside and be
like no that's way more killing a billion people
is way more unacceptable than not becoming
human but if we're dealing with like Madness
to some degree this outsized hunger in this
automaton to be human that it's irrational
but it's extremely real for this automaton it
is a really deep need that really drives this
machine that probably has a soul a conscience or
a personality soul is such an
ambiguous word but something that might
emulate human personality quite well so it's
not missing that but it wants a human body
quite a lot and the sun could even influence
the automatons operating system like with a
virus that makes it like more greedy to be human
sort of take that irrational drive and amplify it
see now there's see how I was like I'm not sure
what these are there's something there's one of
them right there and yes it's a real challenge
to like for this one main creature that we like
and are rooting for to really want that we can
we can get behind that but when we look at it
becoming human versus helping kill a billion
people where it has to be handled right so
that we keep rooting for this Android because
that if if the Android starts going home Diddy
I can't wait to kill a billion people and
eat hot dogs on the beach we're like I'm
not rooting for this creature anymore it's like
you have to get the audience sympathy or I think
the better word is empathy because it's not like
pity sympathy and Furs pity but audience empathy
like they're really rooting for this character
you have to get the audience empathy and keep it
you can get it and then lose it if you don't
handle it right so this has to be handled right
so that the need to become
human has some kind of perceived
equalness in the mind of this automaton based on
this automaton's skewed perception of the world
um
like think of all the things you can do in
a body first of all maybe that body won't
age we're going to put you in a body but 400
years from now it'll still be 27 and you'll
still be the the best surfer on the beach
and like whatever and you can be brain sir
you can you can you can change the face you're
designed to change the face of humanity even
and these billion people who are going
to die they're already starving they're
not going to live that much longer they're
sickly they're in it's like the more that
the sun can amplify
the capabilities of this AI
put on a human body that can
last a thousand years versus the fate of these
people who are already gonna die anyway it's
like it's like getting somebody with terminal
cancer and sending them in as a suicide bomber
it's like there's people that will sign up
for that so if he has to sacrifice people
that are demonstratively not going to live that
long anyway then and he's like I can help the
other seven billion people who really need my
capabilities as a master healer 10 years from
now and I've really Incorporated so much more
with with all the wealth that this company can do
then you begin to it's not like so wildly uneven
from this automaton's point of view even though
we can still go don't be an idiot you're still
killing a billion people but I think that's also
what he's going to discover at the point of crisis
like that the sun's been radically lying to him
or something like that or they the old man who's
back as a human for 20 minutes or whatever is like
he's lying his ass off to you just like he always
did to me he's a monster don't let him get away
with this and then maybe the son comes in and
kills the father again like right who knows but um
we have now the elements of a
dilemma that have to be managed right
but the Deep hunger to become human
and be a savior in many ways like an
Intelligence on an order of magnitude Beyond
any human that ever lived in a human body
that I mean obviously if you like you can
chainsaw it in half but it's not gonna die
from a cold or age or those kind of things
and it's it's interesting and it goes back
to the the trick of how they catch monkeys
in the Philippines which is that they take a
coconut Hollow it out make a hole the size of
a monkey's hand and put rice inside it tie
it to a tree the monkey comes along reaches
in there and grabs the rice but holding
the rice it can't get its hand back out
and the way they catch it is they just walk up
to the monkey and grab it and it's screaming
its head off it wants to run but it will
not let go of the rice like this Android
is like I want life it's just like what Roy
Batty says to Deckard I want more life father
um so that's interesting
and if the Android has been infected
with a virus by the Sun that weakens its
moral compass its ethics its
then there's more gray area and less black and
white inside that Androids ethical Choice system
like where it's starting to agree with the sun
yeah I could see where 300 million of those people
are literally going to be dead in a week anyway
so that doesn't mess up my Android conscience and
it's like he's able to rationalize which is weird
to say for a robot but the more human they become
the more they get better at rationalization
and I don't remember what movie it was
might have been Kiss Kiss Bang Bang like did you
ever try to go a day without a rationalization
something like that that it's key to how
people operate and from my own study of
Hamlet which I was trained on the thing that
I found about Hamlet the more I studied it
was that there was a huge discrepancy between what
he says he's going to do which is everything and
what he actually does which is virtually nothing
is what gets him in the whole royal family killed
because his the ghost of his father says your
uncle killed me go kill him and make things
right and Hamlet who's a Crown Prince
who's been raised as a man of action
that comes right to the front he says
Absolutely I'll go kill him no problem
but then the more he thinks about it he's like
was that a trick of the devil and he's off it
College studying philosophy chasing girls sword
fighting riding horses he has an ideal life and
he's like do I really want to give all that up to
kill my uncle and become king and be stuck in this
cold castle with all these shallow backstabbing
people around and so when it comes time to take
action he's not sure if he should and he lets the
chance go by him and then he beats up on himself
he's like oh I should have just done it all right
so next time next chance boy am I going to do it
and then he doesn't do it again but
he is asking all the right questions
but the next chance he gets to do it he
doesn't and then he's really angry he's
like okay now next time watch out I'm gonna
go crazy I'm really mad now nothing's gonna
stop me and he screws up yet again and so
the discrepancy between what he says he's
going to do which is everything and what he
actually does which is practically nothing
comes down to his ability to lie to himself it's
about self-deception because he believes it when
he says next time I'm really going to do it but
he's lying to himself and the more I studied
Hamlet the more I grew to hate him because he's
really a screw-up like literally a royal screw-up
and he's unable to take decisive action in the
face of an emergency and that's why the whole
family ends up dying but his self-deception is
the mechanism by which he does that and everybody
has self-deception in varying degrees and the more
that I studied Hamlet and the more I grew to hate
him because I see him as an abject screw-up
who can't communicate honestly with himself
so if I notice like oh I'm talking about I'm
doing this and doing this but I'm not actually
doing it I'm like I'm doing a hamlet so get rid
of the crap and just do it or whatever but be
honest with yourself and so it brings up an
interesting question of like self-deception
in a robot as it becomes more human it's able to
lie to itself to help itself get where it needs to
it's like a negative aspect of becoming human so
that's intriguing and it's a it's an interesting
dynamic in the story and something that the sun
might be able to amplify by the introduction of
a virus that's sort of corroding or corrupting
his rigid ethics like Robbie the robot cannot
disobey an order and cannot harm a human being if
one of those things was being corrupted then maybe
sort of could disobey a command or something like
that it's it's an interesting thing to play with
so we still don't have a whole lot of particulars
yet but we have a whole lot more than we did 45
minutes ago and the 36 dramatic situations
just like as I looked at ambition I'm like so
obviously the son who we may not have invented
by that at that point the sun could be extremely
ambitious 8 billion eight trillion dollars
overnight what's not to like and all that
stuff and could the robot have ambition
and how does a robot have ambition and
what are the Ambitions of the founding father or
something like that but you could see how just
thinking about an automaton need to steal
medicine innocent will suffer treachery and
Glory wish granting looking at ambition
through the lens of the lenses of those
raw elements gave rise to several possibilities
and really there was hundreds of possibilities
in on in that but several about ambition jumped
right out and grabbed me by the throat ambition
by the protagonist the automaton or ambition
by the central villain the Sun and that gave us
like something to actually grab onto instead of
just smoking a bucket where there wasn't really
anything you could grab yet now we're beginning
to have some things out of which you can Cobble
together a story and we've gradually been
possibilities have been gelling a few things
have started to really solidify decision and
action even kind of crystallizes like I could
really see that as a hard real thing I
don't know what the resolution might be
I'm getting more of a sense well
now that we have the possibility
of him becoming human and he's like
irrationally over attracted to that
that can counterbalance the unacceptability of
sacrificing a billion people who were gonna die
anyway in other words it's the ability to lie to
yourself and the virus makes him more manipulable
and less rigid it's like when Spock gets some
alien fungus and he's laying around like he's
on catnip instead of going that's not logical so
we're like playing with interesting things and
creating plot devices like corrupting part
of the robot's operating system with a virus
makes certain things that we're
trying to do more tangible and doable
rather than I wish we could had a way to
corrupt his operating system that kind of thing.